welcome back to uncensored Douglas
Murray and Jen Yuga are on bitterly
opposing sides of a debate on Israel's
war in Gaza Millions have watched them
passionately articulate their cases on
this show but never together so tonight
on our final show of the year we've
invited these two big brains to debate
the big outstanding questions on this
conflict how does the war end will
Israel face repercussions for the scale
of its response to October the 7th as it
committed war crimes what is the future
if any for Hamas for Gaza and for the
prospects of a true Palestinian State
most importantly how do we get to peace
well I'm now joined by the author of the
war on the West Douglas Murray and by
Young Turks founder and Democratic
presidential Challenger Jen Yugo welcome
to both of you so I've I've interviewed
you both a lot in this War uh but not
together and Jen I know you felt the
other night when you were debating other
people I didn't really get into a debate
and I think that's fair enough uh and
what I'd like to today really is to be
almost a referee if you like between you
two to articulate your views and to see
if we can reach any points of consensus
um so in that spirit let me start with
you Douglas um I think you're back in
Israel uh is that
right yes I'm in Israel tonight yeah
today it was a sea of other stories have
come out in the last few days which have
been concerning I think for anyone who
like me believes that Israel has not
just a moral duty to defend itself but
has a fundamental right to do so after
what happened on October the 7th and
I've said that clearly from the start
it's always been for me the issue of of
proportionality and it seems that in the
last few days there' have been a number
of incidents which really question
whether Israel is being precise as it
says it is or or indiscriminate and I
would cite the the killing of the three
hostages I would cite the killing of the
two women outside the Catholic church I
would cite the president of the United
States saying that they're using
indiscriminate bombing uh and so on do
you Douglas notwithstanding your Full
Throttle support of Israel does anything
that's been happening make you think
Israel needs to execute this war
differently no and I think that most of
the people who think they know how to
execute this War uh have never executed
a war indeed most people who think they
know how the IDF should be running this
conflict have never been near a conflict
I'm in Israel tonight I was in Gaza and
yesterday um and the examples that you
give by the way peers I don't see why
they show any need to prosecute the war
itself differently I mean just to take
one of them the first example you give
the absolutely tragic awful um um
shooting of these three hostages as they
were coming out but you know the some of
the spin that's been put on that in the
world apart from the Glee of course that
Israel's enemies can't help expressing
um some of the spin on that is is almost
as if it shows the IDF is sort of so
brutal that it even kills Hamas hostages
who are Israeli I just think this is
another example of international media
and others just having this astounding
lack of empathy for the Israeli people
can you imagine what it was like for
those soldiers who were in Gaza knowing
that at any point there were snipers
there are there are uh booby traps
everywhere um people coming out of
tunnels that they've built at British
and American taxpayer expenses and
attacking them can you imagine what it
was like for the soldiers who in that
terrible moment made the lifechanging
mistake of shooting three people who
turned out to be Hamas hostages why
would they on that on that why would
they shoot anyone who was shirtless and
waving an SOS flag I mean why would
whoever they were whether they Israeli
hostages or whether they thought they
were Palestinians why would anyone shoot
anyone who comes out like that that's my
Point that'll that that'll be a matter
for the inquiry into it but uh you know
look it's hardly as if they'd have
wanted to have done that what this
demonstrates is in this incredibly close
conflict in a heavily built up area with
people coming out from all sides firing
shooting detonating uh people make
mistakes of course they do that's just a
human reality of War horrible as it is I
don't think it shows in any way that
Israel is Prosecuting this war wrongly
as the main issue of the war the main
issue of the war is to destroy Hamas no
Israeli of left or right or Center
believes anymore after October the 7th
they can live beside Hamas Hamas has
been given the statelet of Gaza it was
given it in 2006 voted in then killed
their fellow Palestinians in a coup
killed fat Rivals and they've run the
Gaza for almost 18 years now and they've
produced a new gener generation of
people whose main aim in life it seems
according to their textbooks and their
classes is to regard Jews as enemies who
should be killed this is just an
unbelievable waste a waste of life on
every side but apart from anything else
a waste of those Palestinian lives of
children who grew up under hamas's rule
if you can call it that who have been
indoctrinated into becoming sociopaths
by a psychopathic Terror organization
hamz all right Jen you've been listening
to that um is there anything that
Douglas said that you agree
with no nothing not even about the way
Hamas has has presided over Gaza in the
last 18 years yeah so that's a weapon of
mass distraction uh it it's Israel doing
genocide on the Palestinians right now
and uh there's IDF soldiers singing and
and in video that the IDF has confirmed
about how they're going to wipe out the
seed of AMC that is a a verse in the old
Hebrew Bible that talks about exter
terminating ALC so they're talking about
genocide against Palestinians uh
Benjamin Netanyahu has also talked about
uh wiping out amalec these are open
calls for genocide what I find stunning
he you know Douglas mentioned stunning
lack of empathy there's 20,000 dead
people in Palestine right now in Gaza uh
over 8,000 of them are children when 36
Israeli children were killed by Hamas
the world cried out out and I was
brokenhearted over it 36 poor kids dead
in Israel now there's over
8,000 dead kids in Gaza you want to talk
about a stunning lack of empathy
6,400 women slaughtered in Gaza you want
to talk about terrorism they're dropping
unguided bombs 2,000 pound bombs every
one of those bombs is an act of
terrorism and the stunning lack of
empathy towards Palestinian lives is
disgusting but I want to be clear it is
not shared by all Israelis the dad of
one of the hostages who was killed went
on Israeli television and said stop
killing them and he didn't mean the
hostages he meant the Palestinians all
right let me just jump in but before I
go back to dougas respons toly to that P
yeah I I will let you reply to that on
this issue of genocide do you accept
though that hamas's whole on De when it
comes to Israel is genocide they want to
eradicate Israel and kill as many Jews
as they can they've made no secret of
this yeah so uh this is really important
so I have no sympathy for Hamas so I'm
not interested in defending Hamas I
think that's nothing but a distraction
because right now they're not fighting
Hamas they're just killing pales they're
also killing Hamas terrorists they are
they're killing thousands of them barely
no no wait a minute barely but let's go
to your main point okay so the main
point is well Hamas threatens X Y and Z
and has killed 1200 people on October
7th so that is why we have to all worry
about what Hamas might might might might
do hold on hold on let me finish the
point let me finish the point let me
finish the point at what they might
might might do if they had infinite
power the kind of power that Israel has
meanwhile Israel is actually doing the
genocide is actually preventing a
Palestinian State and saying you are not
allowed to exist and if you dare try to
exist we'll kill of your children and
women all right Douglas respond to
that several things first of all anyone
who uses the term genocide in this
context simply doesn't know what they're
talking about or is a malevolent actor
uh I don't know if Mr weer has traveled
at all in his life how far he's traveled
how many conflicts he's seen but I'd
have guessed none and and you clearly
know nothing about this particular
conflict and you've obviously seen none
of it um the genocide that you describe
is such a smear and a liable against the
Jewish state if Israel wanted to commit
genocide I'm sure it could but it
doesn't it doesn't remotely want to and
people like you and other Pro
Palestinian propagandists have spent
years claiming that Israel is committing
genocide in the Gaza by the way the
weirdest thing about this claim is that
the population of the Gaza has grown by
a million in the last 15 or so years so
if Israel was trying to carry out a
genocide it's either the worst
perpetrator of genocide ever or uniquely
poor at performing that task none of the
stats support that ridiculous claim it's
such a weird smear and a liel of Israel
secondly of course you've just rattled
off hamad's figures as every one of your
kind always does thirdly you said that
the world cried World cried you said you
said the people like you who cover for
the Palestinian extremists thirdly you
said that the World cried out for the 36
Israeli dead children no they didn't and
you know that very well you know that
very well if you put up a poster to a
missing dog in any Western City that
poster stays up in city after city in
America posters of abducted Jewish
children including a 10-month-old baby
were put up and were ripped down by
people who have been indoctrinated into
hate of Jews nobody would rip down the
poster of a missing dog but from Dublin
to Berkeley they ripped down posters of
abducted Jewish children so no I don't
think there was let let put dougas Let
me let me make let me make two other
very quick points firstly you said what
Hamas might do as if it was some kind of
hypothetical Hamas showed what they do
what they want to do it showed it on
October the 7th and its leadership as
I'm sure you very well know said that
they would like to repeat that again and
again until they have got rid of every
Jew so I don't know I would trust
hamas's word on that rather than your
interpretation of what you think they
mean when they say that and your and
your generous interpretation of what you
think that means and finally as for
preventing a Palestinian state it is
nonsense that the Israelis have
prevented a Palestinian State they gave
the gazans a Palestinian state in 2005
they gave them a pal inan state in 2005
when every Jewish person was ripped from
their homes in the Gaza by IDF soldiers
and the Palestinian people were given a
state and what did they do they voted in
Hamas who then killed their fellow
Palestinians never had another election
and used all the billions of dollars of
taxpayer funds from the US UK and Europe
to build Terror tunnels and to enrich
themselves so they could live the life
of luxury and katar again and again the
reason there is not a Palestinian state
is because the Palestinian leadership
doesn't want one didn't want one in 1947
it preferred war and it doesn't want one
now Doug let me put one point to you
raised by Queen Rony of of Jordan in a
new piece for I think it was the
Washington Post uh in just over two
months she said Israel's turned Gaza
into a hellscape at least 8,000 children
have died more than the death tolls of
Pearl Harbor September the 11th and
huran Katrina combined these are
gigantic and horrendous numbers of
children being killed do you not have
any quals about the number of children
being killed I mean does it not suggest
that Israel I want to hear I want to qu
I want to hear Queen Ria talking about
this as much as I want to hear Queen
Camila or Megan Markle I mean it's
pathetic Queen Ria is holding on to her
own posess position in Jordan uh the
only piece of advice she has for anyone
is how to marry a king uh Queen Ria
herself is just playing a very nasty
political game if she cared at all and I
would pose this to all the states in the
region if Jordan cared at all for the
Palestinian peoples they would take them
in they would take them in they don't
want them if the Egyptians wanted them
they take them in but they don't you
know why because every country that
takes in the Palestinians gets Terror it
happened in Egypt it happened in Jordan
it happened in Syria it happened in
Lebanon it happened in Tunisia on and on
that's why these people don't really
care about their fellow Muslims they
just care about hating Jews all right
Jake your
response yeah so you asked if he cared
about 8,000 dead babies and his answer
was no uh Queen ra bothers me so a
complete non-answer because he doesn't
care he doesn't think that Palestinians
lives are worth anything he just called
them all terrorist nice you can put that
word always do so hold on I let you talk
for a long time so why don't you shut up
for a second so uh we got all these dead
babies we've got all of these dead
babies that this monster doesn't care
about he says keep bombing them a Former
Intelligence officer said in the Israeli
press they're using AI in a program
called The Gospel where he said it's B
basically a mass assassination Factory
and we could all see it with our own
eyes and you could do all the propaganda
you want No One Believes your nonsense
we see all the dead women we see all the
dead children now Israel has killed 20
times the number of civilians that Hamas
killed so would I want Hamas in charge
of Israel never never I don't trust them
and I don't believe that they would be
benign so all of this propaganda about
oh like oh people don't mind Hamas no we
mind Hamas we mind we terribly what
happened on October 7th and I'm now
showing you different israelies that
have said that it's a problem and I I
want peace and security for both Israel
and Palestine and this does not get
Israel any peace or security but when
you ask the other side do you mind T of
thousands of civilians that have been
murdered incinerated alive body parts
picked out of rubble little babies
killed over and over again in what is
even the Israeli Prime Minister is
referring to as amalak meaning an
extermination of the Palestinian people
and I must clarify the difference
between a genocide and a hoca a genocide
is when you target a specific people and
kill a lot of civilians cban where 6,000
people were killed was considered a
genocide so it is it doesn't mean you
try to murder every single person in
that that is a
holocaust one second one second before
before I go to Douglas Jen one question
you want to get rid of Hamas too as does
Douglas as do I if you don't do it the
way that Israel is currently doing it
given that they live amongst the
population how else do you do
it yeah there's an excellent way to do
it and there's the right way to do it so
let me explain so War this guy talks
about oh I love War I go to all the
conflict zones so by watching it and
rooting on for more death I know
something about conflict you know
nothing so here's what reality is war
gets you more war but peace actually
works so when Israel did a peace deal
with Egypt not only were the Egyptians
safe but the Israelis became safer that
peace deal has held for decade after
decade so how do you do a peace deal in
this case what you do is you make a you
do the two-state solution now and you do
it with the Palestinian Authority in the
West Bank and if you then have a
Palestinian State the Palestinian
Authority would have the credibility to
drive out Hamas from Gaza that is a
realistic plan for both peace security
for Israel and the Palestinians and
driving out Hamas the idea that you're
going to kill
200,000 more civilians in Gaza and it's
going to drive
out that respond to that first of all
first of all I mean your other guest I
mean I don't know what kind of a
creature he is he's a kind of low grade
Thug as far as I can see he's listened
to nothing I've said yeah yeah I know
because
I'm I'll tell you I'll tell you no it's
not that at all it's not that at all I
just think that you're a very I think
you're just a very low rent racist but
anyway let me just get on to it you say
you say first of all you say I don't
care about the death of Palestinian
children yes I do care I care very
deeply about it but I also know that the
responsibility for their deaths lies on
Hamas which has misgoverned their
society for the last 16 years and now
has been leading the country into being
in a war with Israel so yes it's on
Hamas this as for seeing Wars by the way
I just mentioned about seeing Wars
because as far as I can see you're very
ill traveled as well as rather ill
lettered and Ill spoken and I mentioned
that I cover Wars and go towards because
I happen to think myself that it's worth
seeing things with your own eyes
including things that you don't
particularly like but you report the
truth I don't know if you ever even
leave your own bedroom and I can tell
already that you don't because you've
already said something that demonstrates
you know nothing about this conflict you
have just demonstrated it in the
following terms you said that this is
why we need to push for a two-state
solution and give legitimacy to the
Palestinian Authority I'll tell you
something you don't know because I guess
you spent no time in the West Bank have
you I'll tell you something you probably
don't know the Palestinian Authority fat
celebrated the 7th of October massacres
I'll give you another fact which
demonstrates you know nothing about this
and clearly haven't ever visited any
Palestinians in the West Bank as I have
if there was an election tomorrow in the
West Bank the reason why there isn't one
is because if there was an election
tomorrow in the West Bank Hamas would
win so your idea of a two-state solution
I'm afraid you are so out of date and
you really should leave your bedroom
because in this region nobody thinks
that there is a two-state solution on
the table because there is not a viable
negotiating partner but I just want to
make one other main point you have gone
on and on tonight throwing accusations
out against the Jewish State against me
it's the sort of thing you do I know
you're a sort of sort of online pugilist
and think you can run for office and
good luck with that but I'd just like to
point out that you only really get
animated if the Jews are involved and I
can tell that for the following reason I
mean your surname is weager isn't it 1
million weager Muslims in China have
been put in concentration camps in the
last decade and PE you know people of
your ilk never really care about that do
you because it's not the Jews doing it
it's a Chinese Communist party at the
moment one million P Pak one million
people who are from Pak who are in
Pakistan at the moment who are your
fellow Muslims and who happen to be
Afghan and I don't think you care about
them do you one million Afghans are
currently being forcibly deported from
Pakistan to Afghanistan you don't care
about that you're not riled up about
that you're not riled up about what the
jungo weed are currently doing in Sudan
where thousands and thousands of people
are being attacked by the by the the
islamist militia there you don't care
about any of that you get exercised and
you rile up what little base you have of
Mal contents because you're riled up
when the Jews do anything it's perfectly
obvious okay Jen your response yeah okay
first of all uh my last name is yuger
we're named after the weager Turks in
China and we talked about that on spoken
up then yes yes I we've talked about it
endlessly but you don't know that and
you don't watch the show nobody watches
your show nobody does watch your show
yeah well okay again you're interrupting
me when I was kind enough to let you do
go on with your mad ramblings so it how
nobody watches the show we have five
billion views a year uh I don't know
what piddling outf you're on or what
little substack or whatever the hell you
write on so the reason we're incredibly
popular we fight for shut up we fight
for all innocent civilians so yes we've
covered all of those conflicts yes I'm
against fundamentalist Islam no question
about it I'm against fundamentalist
religions of all kind in terms of uh you
every right-wing supporter of Israel
their only tactic is hey don't look at
the 8,000 murdered children don't look
at the 6,400 murdered women don't look
at the fact that all the hospitals in
Northern Gaza have been shut down don't
look at the fact that four out of five
people in Northern Gaza are starving
right now and half the people in
southern Gaza are starving instead
anti-semite anti-semite now I wait a
minute I just told you how much I want
peace security for Israel how much I
hated what happened on October 7th what
you don't know is I started The Young
Turks with two Jewish friends and so the
whole program is both Jews and Muslims
you know nothing you know nothing I have
Jewish family and friends why the War
gods as they go to Israel I want them to
be safe okay so I have shown empathy for
all civilians throughout everything I
have ever done but all you have is
hatred oh he's an anti-semite kill the
Muslims kill the Palestinians and once
we kill them by the way we'll blame them
for it we had to Israel had to murder
all those babies in Palestine because
Hamas made us Ste it then why are you
listening to Hamas why are you letting
Hamas drive your agenda well you don't
have to kill those civilians it's a mass
assassination
Factory we are what 9 weeks into this
war 20,000 people according to the Hamas
run health authority but the numbers
have not been questioned by other
official bodies 20,000 people so have
died on the Palestinian side and it is
estimated from the IDF that they they
say they've killed 7,000 or so Hamas
terrorists that number has not been
verified but if you take that as being
accurate that's 20% of the estimated
number number of Hass terrorists that
exist therefore there's 80% still to be
eliminated which at this rate would take
another 8 to 10 months and would lead to
potentially several hundred thousand
civilians being killed and pretty much
all of Gaza being obliterated with
nowhere for the 2 million who've been
displaced to go back to so my question
for you is if this is the game plan by
Israel to finish Hamas right to Bas
terrorist what is left after that they
talk about the day after the war what
does it look like who runs Gaza where do
these people go back to live in other
words what actually happens if Israel is
successful however long it takes in
eliminating
Hamas well first of all I just have have
to add you you quite rightly said it
appears that the figures you gave are
Hamas figures and we do have to treat
them with more than a grain of salt um
as for again uh my counterpart here goes
on about uh the deliberate genocide of
children and and women I mean I know and
this is a sort of thing I I think you do
you sort of claim that there are bombs
being deliberately dropped on children
and old women why would Israel want to
drop bombs deliberately on children or
old women I mean you just again it's
just a shame you don't get out and see
anything um the Israelis do an
incredibly careful campaign before
bombings to try to make sure that
civilians are warned to live leave areas
that are about to be attacked everybody
knows that everybody in the region knows
that it's a shame that that fact hasn't
got to you as it happens the whole
question you raised p is a very very
complex one I don't have the answer I
don't believe anyone does have the
answer about the day after uh nobody
wants to rule the Gaza uh the Israelis
used to be in charge of it they left as
I say in 2005 to the last Jew they were
all taken out of their houses Israel
doesn't want to rule the Gaza now who
can rule the Gaza hamaz clearly cannot
because they set it up as as a terrorist
stat can some fat like Authority be
encouraged to take it over possibly
possibly I spoke to one Palestinian
analyst earlier today who said that
actually just as I said earlier that an
election in the West Bank today would
elect Hamas perhaps an election to
tomorrow if it was to happen and I'm not
sure if that's going to be a good idea
might even actually elect not Hamas
Palestinians to power but it's a heck of
a risk the reality is that the only
solution to Gaza that anyone can see I
can can imagine is it it has to be a
solution which involves multiple players
in the region the question of the Gaza
is a very complex question it used to be
ruled by Egypt used to be run by Egypt
can Egypt have a role in my view it has
to have a role can Jordan be involved in
my view yes it has to have a role can
the Gulf States including those who've
been pumping money to Hamas have some
kind of role yes I would hope so it
cannot be Israel's task alone to deal
with the question of the Gaza it has to
involve multiple players in the region
but there's one kicker to that which is
that none of the Arabs in this region
that I'm sitting in care a jot about the
Palestinians they really do not if they
did for all of their talk they would
have done something they would not have
decided to keep the Palestinians out as
they have in country after Country Queen
Ria can invite the uh gazans into Jordan
she can invite the West Bank palestin
Ians into Jordan she doesn't Egypt could
open its border with Gaza it doesn't the
Egyptian border with Gaza is firmer and
more closely locked than the Israeli
ones there are gazen workers who until
the atrocities of October the 7th every
day were going through the erets
crossings and others to work in Israel
and to earn a decent living were there
workers going in Daily into Egypt no
because the Egyptians don't want
Palestinians in their country
so the only solution is a regional one
but I'm afraid in this region there are
very few people who care about the
Palestinians okay uh Douglas you had the
first word uh Jen I'll give you the last
word I want to preface it by saying that
it's been reported today this has come
from uh hamas's uh uh statements
apparently picked up by newspapers in
America that there was a new hostage
deal offered which was that Hamas will
ask Will you release the 40 women and
children you still have captive uh in
return for a week-long ceasefire and
they apparently have rejected that so I
think that when we talk about uh
behavior on both sides the mere fact
that there are still 40 women and
children in the clutches of Hass and God
knows what they're doing to those poor
women um that should be noted too there
are still innocent people being held in
the most appalling conditions by herass
and that is also motivating Israel's
response I'll give you the last word Jen
yeah so I I wish to God that they would
release those women and and children I
think it's immoral to keep them it's
wrong in every way uh but Israel kills
more than 40 women and children every
single day uh all completely innocent uh
look even if you take idf's outlandish
numbers of 7,000 Hamas Fighters killed
that means their kill ratio of civilians
to Fighters is still worse than hamas's
and they have now killed 20 times the
number of civilians that Hamas has
killed so when when Douglas talks about
driving them into Egypt or Jordan that's
just ethnic cleansing they live in Gaza
so if you push them out and they say
well you're all Arabs anyway why don't
you just go live somewhere else in the
region that's the definition of ethnic
cleansing that is outrageous and he says
it with Bly with no concern because
Palestinian lives don't matter and you
ask them hey how many Palestinians can
you Poss ibly killed and he never
answered the question so the reality is
you cannot kill your way out of this
conflict the more that they killed the
more what do you think that the
Palestinians are going to feel what
would you feel if your family was
butchered if their heads were crushed by
a bomb that was dropped on a building if
they were lit on fire by the bombs that
were dropped what would you do you'd
fight back the rest of your life and
then they are o permanently occupied now
now Netanyahu says he was proud that he
did prevented a Palestinian State and
that he will continue to prevent a
Palestinian State he is not a partner
for peace or he profits from war his
whole career is about perpetrating War
not just to murder Palestinians but it
keeps Israel unsafe for eternity the
whole point of Israel is to be a safe
haven for oppress Jews throughout the
world it cannot be a safe haven as long
as you're imprisoning 5 million and
Palestinians and saying we are never
ever going to let you go and if you ever
dare oppose us we will kill your women
and children not in prison it's
disgusting they're not in prison I would
urge you again I urge you again I'd Ur
urge you again Chen leave your bedroom
sometime and come to this region see it
for yourself I thought I was supposed to
get the last word this talking about
bedrooms care about the babies you care
about the women Douglas why don't you
admit you don't care about dead
Palestinian babies dead pal
you don't it Israel Israel Israel you
say right or wrong no matter how many
people they have murdered no matter how
many kids they approached death don't
care because you don't care about human
beings all you want is some sort of
War US state
Etc
war going to wrap it I got to say listen
little man I think we actually had a
very man Super Evil you don't mind the
death of of people War mongering Jak
let's not descend into this I actually
think with with a few exceptions we had
a good debate there right I understand
passions Run High I think it's a shame
whenever I do these debates when it gets
ad homenum in the way that it has
occasionally tonight but I do think
we've also had some really smart takes
from both sides about what is going on
and where we need to get to I think we
can all agree on one thing we all want
to end up with peace here somehow it's
going to be horrendously difficult uh
it's very complicated that's not true
but I do I don't I don't actually think
knowing both of you as I do I don't
believe the charge that neither of you
care is true I think you do care about
all the lies that are being LA and I
think that we we should start from an
acceptance we all care and then try and
be more constructive but listen I thank
you both for joining me I wish you both
a Merry Christmas I'll see you both no
doubt in the new year and I thank you
both I thank you both for your regular
contributions to the show particularly
since this War started because I I
really do appreciate it and I want to
hear both sides and I think you both
articulate your cases extremely
powerfully so thank you both very
much thank thank
you